Guten Tag, Adid ist mein Name.
Ich bin der Dienstag in der Art, heute ich übernachmache um Sie. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Eleni Meier.
Meier, Frau Meier, können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname für mich langsam bestabieren.
Genau, EL, E-N-I. Eleni ist mein Vorname.
Meier und Meier, Meier, M-E-I. Entschuldigung.
M-L-I-E-R. Meier, meine Nachname.
Okay, Meier, Frau Meier, so spiele ich Ihre Name richtig aus?
Genau, genau.
Bevor wir über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen, würde ich gerne einfach allgemeine Fragen über Sie stellen.
So, erstmal, wie alt sind Sie, Frau Meier?
Ich bin 48.
Wann sind Sie genau umgebaut?
Ach gut, ich habe mich nicht überlegt, moment, bitte.
Ja, ich bin 2., 3., 1974 geboren.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Frau Meier?
Ich bin 1 Meter 56 groß.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
71 und auch ein bisschen mehr, vielleicht 200 Gramm.
Okay, und was machen Sie beruflich, Frau Meier?
Ich bin Schuhkauffrau.
Okay, Frau Meier, was kann ich für Sie tun heute?
Was hat Sie zu uns geführt?
Ach wissen Sie, Herr Doktor, ich habe seit gestern Abend sehr stark Oberbauchschmerzen.
Ich kann nichts essen, nichts trinken seit gestern Abend, das ist echt schlimm.
Und wann liegt ganz genau Ihre Schmerzen, Frau Meier?
Oberbauch, aber rechte Seite, linke Seite?
Ja, ich kann nicht richtig unterscheiden, vielleicht rechte Seite.
Und strahlen Ihre Schmerzen in irgendwohin, in Ihrem Körper aus?
Ja, in die rechte Schulter fühle ich mich auch.
Auf einer Scala, wenn Sie einschätzen können, von 0 bis 10,
sehen Sie, dass Sie schlechte Schmerzen bisher gefühlt haben.
Wie stark Ihre Schmerzen?
Eigentlich schätze ich etwa bei 7.
Haben Sie gestern etwas Besonderes bemerkt, gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für Ihre Schmerzen?
Ich bin nicht sicher, aber gestern Abend hat mein Mann Geburtstag, deshalb haben wir Gänsebraten gegessen.
Und danach, oder seitdem habe ich diese Schmerzen.
Aber was ich jetzt sagen würde, etwa seit 2 Wochen nach fettigem Essen,
ähnliche Beschwerden hatte ich schon, aber dieses Mal bis jetzt immer wieder andauern
und immer wieder stärker geworden ist.
Nach dem Essen ist es plötzlich eingefangen, oder?
Genau, ja.
Okay, Frau Amoyah, ich würde gerne hier erst mal einen Kurs zusammenfassen.
Sie sind bei mir heute, weil gestern ob er auch aufdrehtende Schmerzen haben.
Und seitdem haben Sie gar keine Appetit, können Sie gar nichts essen und trinken.
Ihre Schmerzen strahlt in richtig Schülter aus.
Sie haben schon Ihre Schmerzen für ein Skala als 7 eingeschätzt.
Gleichzeitig haben Sie das berichtet, dass Sie seit 2 Wochen nach dem fettigen Essen
diese Schmerzen noch immer haben, aber seit gestern ist es andauern und stärker geworden.
Ist das ja richtig?
Ja, es ist alles richtig.
Okay, zwischendurch haben Sie etwas Etwaschen?
3 Mal.
Und wie ist Ihre Stuhlgang, so Durchfall oder etwas anderes,
haben Sie das bemerkt beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, beim Stuhlgang gibt es keine Besonderheit.
Wie ist Ihre Wasserlösung, ob Sie etwas besonders beim Wasserlöschen bemerken?
Ja, heute habe ich bemerkt, dass mein Urin noch dunkler ist.
Bis gestern trinke ich etwa 2 Liter am Tag, aber ich weiß nicht, warum es so passiert.
Jetzt echt dunkler Urin habe ich.
Haben Sie gar keine Schmerzen, oder?
Bei Masalasen?
Ja, genau, beim Masalasen.
Nur wie gesagt, Farbeveränderung habe ich bemerkt, ansonsten nichts.
Okay, ist das Ihnen gerade übel?
Ja, zu viel. Deshalb kann ich nichts essen.
Normalerweise mein Appetit ist so, aber ich habe Angst vor Erbrechen,
deshalb möchte ich nichts essen.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es eine schwierige Situation ist.
Aber ich finde mich auf jeden Fall heute dafür eine Lösung.
Darüber meine letzte Frage.
Wenn Sie eine bestimmte Bewegung oder eine bestimmte Position
mit Ihrem Schmerzen verschlechtert oder vernegen erlachtet,
gibt es eine bestimmte Position dafür?
Nein, das ist unabhängig von Bewegung, aber ich kann nicht beschreiben.
Manchmal kommt die Schmerzen echt schlimmer.
Ich kann nie mehr bewegen, manchmal ein bisschen ruhiger geworden,
dann kann ich noch etwas machen.
Dann können wir sagen, dass Ihre Schmerzen krampartiger ist?
Ja, genau, das ist das richtige Wort.
Okay, Frage mal her.
Haben Sie das gemessen?
Ich fühle mich warm, aber ich habe meine Temperaturen nichts gemessen.
Okay. Wie ist Ihre Schlacht?
Könnten Sie schlafen?
Gestern Abend kann ich nicht richtig einschlafen,
aber ansonsten habe ich keine Schlachtstörung.
Okay.
Sind Sie abgenommen oder zugenommen?
Haben Sie etwas Besonderes bemerkt?
Nein, mein Gewicht ist immer gleich geblieben.
Nach Schweiß?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt, ich glaube nicht.
Leiden Sie an chronische Krankheiten,
so in meiner Hochblutdruck oder Südkrankheit oder etwas anderes?
Ich leide unter Migräne.
Ansonsten?
Wie bitte?
Ansonsten? Ja, keine andere.
Ansonsten keine chronische Erkrankung,
ich weiß es nicht, dass es auch darunter gestalt wird,
aber ich habe schon Rückenschmerzen.
Und mein Arzt hat gesagt,
dass es ein Perni- oder Bandscheibenvorfall deshalb bin ich operiert worden,
aber seit der Operation habe ich keine mehr Schmerzen.
Dann Schritt für Schritt.
Erst mal, so würde ich gerne fragen, für Ihre Migräne
nehmen Sie eine bestimmte Medikamente regelmäßig ein?
Nicht regelmäßig, wenn ich Migränatacke hätte,
nehme ich normal genein.
Nehmen Sie andere Medikamente regelmäßig ein?
Nein, keine.
Über Ihre Operation, ist es komplikationsgebot?
Nein, ich bin nur zwei Tage im Krankenhaus gewesen,
dann die Nachsorgeuntersuchungen sind immer besser.
Das ist sehr gut, das freut mich.
Sind Ihnen irgendwie andere Operationen oder Eingriffbekannt
oder nur wegen Ihren Rückenschmerzen, Ihre Bandscheiben verlassen?
Ich habe zwei Kinder, beide habe ich mit Kaiser-Schnitt bekommen.
Beide Geburt war komplikationslos, oder?
Genau, beide sind komplikationslos.
Sind Ihnen irgendwie eine Allergie gegen etwas bekannt?
Haben Sie irgendwie gegen etwas?
Genau, ja.
Keine Medikamentenallergie habe ich, aber ich bin allergisch gegen Nüsse und Tierhaare.
Sind Sie durchgeimpft, Frau Meyer?
Gegen was?
Gegen die Corona- und andere Impfungen auch, war ich.
Sind Sie sich irgendwie geimpft?
Eigentlich, in der Kinderheit habe ich meine alle Impfungen bekommen, sobald ich weiß.
Und gegen Covid-19 bin ich dreimal geimpft.
Und im Herst habe ich auch Gripp und Schutzimpfungen bekommen.
Frau Meyer, waren Sie im Ausland seit sechs Monaten, letzte sechs Monaten?
Im letzten sechs Monaten war ich nicht.
Und leben Sie allein oder mit Ihrem Partner, Partnerin oder mit Ihrem Kinder?
Eigentlich, ich bin verheiratet und wie gesagt, ich habe zwei Kinder, wir leben zusammen.
Wenigstens, Ihre Eltern noch immer?
Meine Eltern, genau, leben beide.
Haben Ihre Eltern bestimmte Krankheiten, wie gesagt, Ob Blutdruck oder Superkrankheit,
oder irgendetwas anderes?
Sind Sie ganz gesund?
Nein, die sind natürlich älter.
Ich bin 48 schon und mein Vater leide an Zuckerkrankheit und erhöhte Blutdruck.
Und bei ihm auch einen Asthma bekannt.
Und mein Mutter leide aktuell an, wie kann man sagen, die Lipidwerte ist immer im Blut erhöht.
Deshalb dagegen kriegt sie Medikamente.
Und sie hatte etwa vor zehn Jahren einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Haben Sie Geschwester, Frau Meyer?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Ein Bruder?
Und ist er gesund?
Leider.
Ach Gott, das ist echt traurig, aber etwa zehn Monate vorher hat er einen Herzinfarkt bekommen und daran gestorben.
Ich bin ja richtig leid, Frau Meyer.
Ich komme von Ihnen.
Ich geschwäge Zeitpunkte für Sie.
Ja.
Frau Meyer, haben Sie noch einmal Ihre Regelblutung?
Seit zwei Jahren nicht mehr.
Es kann ein bisschen unangenehm sein, aber ich muss diese Fragen für meine alle Patienten stellen.
Wie ist gerade Ihre Geschlechtsverkehr?
Haben Sie regelmäßig oder sind Sie noch einmal aktiv?
Ich kann einfach sagen, die früher, ich habe keine Veränderungen bemerkt.
Okay.
Brauchen Sie auch, Frau Meyer?
Nein, ich habe bisher nie geraucht.
Das ist ja richtig gut für Sie und für Ihre Kinder.
Kennen Sie Alkohol?
Ab und zu, wenn ich mit meiner Freundin getroffen habe,
ein, zwei Gläser Rotwein, vielleicht im Monat, vielleicht alle zwei Monate.
Meine letzte Frage, nehmen Sie bitte nicht übel.
Ich muss diese Frage auch für meine alle Patienten stellen.
So ist eine routine Frage.
So, haben Sie in Ihrem Leben irgendwann mit den Drogen eine Kontakte gehabt?
Nein, keine.
Okay, Frau Meyer.
Wir gehen gerade durch mit meiner Frage.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich möchte kurz fragen.
Wie lange musste ich diesen Schmerzen durchhalten?
Weil ich bin echt seit gestern Abend fertig.
Ich bin raus, Herr Doktor.
Ich möchte irgendwie ein Schmerzmittel oder so etwas.
Ich habe bisher keine Medikamente eingenommen,
weil meine Freundin von mir hat mir gesagt, Bauchschmerzen ist wichtig.
Deshalb versuche ich durchzuhalten.
Aber wie gesagt, ich bin raus.
Ab jetzt möchte ich nichts weiter hinvertragen.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen.
So, erst mal untersuche ich Ihnen förblich.
Dann nehme ich Blut ab und brauchen wir auch die Rindprobe von Ihnen.
Und machen wir Ultraschall und hochwaschendlich am Ende brauchen wir andere Untersuchungen auch.
Aber ich kann Ihnen ganz genau versichern,
dass unsere Diagnoseprozesse nicht mehr lang gedauert.
Und dann kommen wir Ihnen mit einer Lösung.
Und bis dahin, nachdem wir untersuchen,
geben wir Ihnen auf jeden Fall eine Schmerzmittel.
Dann müssen Sie nicht mehr Ihre Schmerzen aufhalten.
So, sind Sie damit einverstanden, Frau Meyer?
Ja, aber ich möchte auch eine andere Frage stellen.
Ultraschall ist eine diagnostische Methode,
die wir benutzen.
Und es ist ganz schmerzlos.
Wir brauchen gar nicht.
Es funktioniert mit Geräuschsignalen.
Und dann können wir als Art unter die Ihre Haut,
welche Gewieben oder welche Veränderungen
oder welche Schwierungen da aufgetreten ist.
Aber es ist, wie ich gesagt habe, keine Nadel da gibt,
keine Schmerzen, keine Beteubungsmittel, nicht eigentlich.
Alles klar.
Meine andere Kollegin haben die Fragen,
so sie können gerne stellen.
Hat jemand eine Frage oder?
Ich denke keine Frage.
Können wir als Art, die Geschichte führen?
Okay, guten Abend, meine Oberarztin.
Ich habe heute eine Patiente als stationär aufgenommen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit, dass wir darüber diskutieren können?
Ja, bitte schön.
Elinemayah, Sie, die, die, die
48 Jahre alt und über Gewicht, die Frau.
Und sie ist bei uns gelandet, weil sie seit gestern
Oberbauchbereich Schmerzen hat.
Und seitdem hat sie gar keine Appetit.
Und sie hat das berichtet, seine Schmerzen,
seine Schmerzen hatten rechtlich Schulter ausgestrahlt.
Ausgestrahlen.
Und gestern Abend hat sie mit, mit, mit ihrem Mann
so eine, nach, nachdem der Abendbrot gegessen hat,
hat die, haben die Schmerzen blödlich angefangen.
Und zwischendurch starker geworden.
Und sie hat ihre Schmerzen als Kampfartiger beschrieben
und mit einem Schmerzskala mit sieben von zehn eingeschätzt.
Und außerdem hat sie zwischendurch dreimal erbruschen.
Aber abgesehen davon hat sie beim Stuhlgang nicht bemerkt.
Aber beim Wasserlassen, so hat sie eine dunklere Urin,
nämlich dunklere Urin.
Und außerdem hat sie das auch berichtet,
so seit zwei Wochen habe sie diese ähnliche Schmerzen
und Beschwerden, insbesondere nachfittige Essen.
Sie hat sich warm gefühlt, aber sie hat seine Temperatur
nicht gemessen.
Sie hat sich nicht verändert, so bei der B-Symptome.
Alles ist unauffällig.
Und außerdem mit ihren Vorerkrankungen.
So leidet sie an Migräne.
Und bei Bedarf nimmt sie dafür Neuvalgin ein.
Und für ihre so seitliche Schmerzen hat sie nichts genommen.
Und in Operation geschieht hat sie vorher
eine wegen der Rückenschmerzen operiert geworden.
Und seine zwei Kinder, sie mit der Kaiserschnitte operiert geworden,
aber alle Operationen waren komplikationlos.
Und sie hatte allergegen den Nüsse und ihre Haare.
Sie ist gewusstet und sie hat seine alle Impfungen geimpft lassen.
Und außerdem raucht sie auch nicht.
Und Familienanamnense war unauffällig mit ihrer Symptome.
Und vor zwei Jahren hat sie ihre Menopose.
Deswegen seit zwei Jahren hat sie gar keine Menage und Regelblutung.
Sie trinkt nur Alkohol als soziale Trinker.
Und mit den Drogen haben wir gar keine Kontakt.
Und nachdem diese Anamnese, würde ich gerne sie erst mal körperlich untersuchen
und Blut abnehmen und auf jeden Fall Urin-Probe fragen.
Aber mit diesem Anamnese gehe ich davon, dass sie eine Colensitis
oder mit einem Stein mit einer Colensitis kann auch sein.
Die Bereiche passt diese Krankheit ganz gut.
Und Australien steht auch da.
Und seit zwei Wochen nach dem der Fettige essen.
Sie sind eine bestimmte Symptome dafür.
Deswegen nach körperlicher Untersuchung würde ich erst beim Ultraschall weitergehen.
Und wenn ich die unter dem Unterschall nicht sehe, entweder Computer-Tomographie.
Aber am Ende würde ich die ECTA durchführen,
weil es gleichzeitig diagnostische Methode und Behandlungsmethode ist.
Schön. Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie diese Patientin stationär aufgenommen haben.
Haben Sie Ihr Temperatur gemessen?
Ich habe gar keine Zeit für körperliche Untersuchungen.
Aber während ich körperliche Untersuche,
messe ich auf jeden Fall Ihre vitale Werte nochmal.
Okay. Und welche Laboruntersuchung würden Sie jetzt durchführen?
Ich würde gerne die Enzymbarte von den Leber gucken.
Gleichzeitig würde ich gerne die Enzymbarte von den Pankers gucken.
Und außerdem würde ich gerne wissen,
was ist die Grund für diese dunklere Urin?
Sie haben auch einen Verdacht auf eine Entschündung in der Gallenblase.
Möchten Sie auch Entschündungparameter gucken?
Ja, richtig. Genau.
Ich habe eine Entschündungparameter, die ist CHP und BCGA,
die ist auf jeden Fall COKK.
Wahrscheinlich, ob wir Lämpositos haben.
Okay. Und wenn Sie eine Abdomenutrischal durchführen werden,
bei der Sonografie, was könnten Sie darstellen?
Ich frage Sie, wie es sich bei der Gallenblase zu Steinen sieht.
Oder bei der COKK.
Aber bei den Forschungen,
es ist wahrscheinlich nicht schwierig,
bei der Utrischal eine Steine zu sehen.
Aber anstatt der Stattung kann man die verdichte COKWand sehen.
Entschündete COKWand.
So würde das erwarten.
Und wieder die Wände, oder der Wand von Gallenblase,
erwarten Sie auch Verdigung?
Es kommt darauf an eigentlich nicht.
Aber wenn es eine Kulisistik ist, erwartet er auch.
Und als Therapie?
Was könnten Sie einhalten?
Eine Kulisistik.
Man kann auch mit den anderen Behandlungsmethoden weitergehen,
aber diese Probleme in den fünf Jahren nochmal und nochmal auftreten.
Deswegen ist gerade die Kulisistik im Polen.
Ich würde die Kulisistik durchführen.
Das ist echt richtige Therapie.
Aber bis die Kulisistik braucht dieser Patient noch etwas?
Schmeckt es mit.
Sonst?
Sonst fast.
Sie dürfen nicht essen.
Aber wie kann das sein?
Ich setze mir nicht gerade ein.
Erst mal empfehlen wir Karenz mit dem Essen.
Karenz, ja.
Und danach natürlich einen Zugang legen.
Und danach Flüssigkeit zuvor, die braucht auf jeden Fall.
Und natürlich ein Schmerzmittel.
Ich möchte besonders, oder trotz unseres Wissens in der
Deutschland kann man einfach ein Schmerzmittel geben.
Weil die denken, die Patienten jetzt unter uns, unter Ärzte,
deshalb wenn es irgendwelche Komplikation vorgegeben ist,
könnten wir einfach diese Situation überstehen.
Deshalb, wenn die Patienten sagt, ich habe Schmerzen,
ich würde gerne empfehlen,
bieten Sie bitte erst mal Schmerzmittel.
Ich habe das vor der Anamnesigespreche auch.
Weil das ist sehr selten.
Und in Deutschland, das ist Leitlinien gerecht.
Das kann ich sagen, in der Leitlinie gibt es auch so.
Darf man einfach ein Schmerzmittel bieten?
Aber das ist ja sehr so.
Ich habe schon darüber gelesen.
Vor kurzem habe ich darüber auch gelesen.
Und insbesondere für die Appendoktemie zum Beispiel.
Da haben wir immer in der Medizin verpültet und meine ganze Leben darüber
so gelernt, bis apfandesitis fest als Diagnose ist,
dürfen wir gar keine Schmerzmittel geben,
weil es unsere Untersuchungsresultate so verandern.
Das ist eigentlich ein Sprachprüfung.
Deshalb sollten wir so viel besprechen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eine Kulissistitis oder Kulitiasis.
Und Ultraschall ist immer unter dem Hand.
Beim Gespräch kann man auch durch Ultraschall gucken
und direkt eine Diagnose vorgehen.
Deshalb ist das nicht so schlimm.
Dann frage ich,
kann ich sagen, fast alle Internisten können Ultraschall.
wenn meine Patente die Schmerz hat,
dann frage ich, ob sie eine Schmerz sind.
Brauchen Sie Schmerzmittel
oder könnten Sie bis Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Dürfen Sie das fragen?
Okay, mache ich das schon.
Meine letzte Frage, meine Oberarztin.
Sollen wir Antibiotiktherapie jetzt oder während des OP durchführen?
Gibt es Unterschied dafür?
Gute Frage.
Wir haben jetzt keine feste Diagnose.
Wenn es Kulissistitis ist,
dann könnten wir direkt ein Antibiotikum einleiten.
Aber aktuell kann ich bei dieser Söße nicht sicher sagen,
wenn es konkretitis ist.
Sollen wir ein anderes Antibiotikum ausfehlen?
Zum Beispiel bei der Kulissistitis
können wir einfach eine Sepulosporin anordnen.
Aber bei der Pankretitis
muss man auf jeden Fall ein Karbopenem einleiten.
Deshalb aktuell braucht sie nicht so eilig ein Antibiotika.
Aber nachdem wir die Diagnose festgestellt haben,
dann sollten wir das einleiten.
Okay, danke schön.
Danke.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel, wenn wir ein Kulissistikdomiplanen,
eine preoperative Prophylaxe ist schon genug.
Okay.
Wenn keine Komplikation braucht,
dann braucht man keine mehr Antibiotikum nach der OP.
Hat jemand noch andere Fragen?
Oder haben Sie noch andere?
Ich bin durch mit der Frage.
Alles. Das war die Kulissistikdomiplanen.